elloumi au sommet francescu paoli sert à
l'indycar
georges pernoud s'apprête à treilles
feuilla espérant des sas en or elle se
leurrer de barthélémy mois son père je
vais faire ce qu'ils font
camille jeanne d'armement aspect tovo
comment voyez vous la suite des
événements majeurs sont morts je veux
que tu me chante une chanson
faites moi plaisir vous dites oh rien à
ma mère tu vas voir si je vais fermer ma
gueule bah oui
pas fameux 5 c'est dégueulasse pour ça
que notre que tu es sous la moyenne
tourne autour de la team ico coût est
pas content avec sandra paoli
tu as cru que tu pouvais monter une
affaire avec sept buts sans mon
autorisation
tarek du poème baiser qu'est ce qu'on
fait est ton avis
pourtant vaincu l'équipe a fait sa
tonalité fout de ta gueule au caire sous
merde on en problème avec ton copain et
aux bonnes règles
ce qu'il faut faire il faut en croûte
bien voilà ce qu'il faut faire
pascal pascal
le frère me sentir je sais que c'est pas
ce qu'il y'a tu veux m'arrêter
barrett moi c'est lui qui avait rendez
vous avec même que c'est lui qui était
avec eux c'est pas lui
oui les douze mois on reste comme des
cas je balançais
on te laissera jamais de faire tant
casino au faut que tu bouges et même si
quelqu'un t'appelle pour te dire que
tout était arrangé que tu vois bien tu
le crois pas ce qui est sûr c'est que
jean moulin fait à l'envers
bon je pars bouge pas
s'est amoindri que le problème parce que
je fais la bonne place pour le faire on
va venger sébastien que ça coûte un
million 10 millions ben je sais pas
grand chose des affaires de sandra paoli
mois vous allez trouver du balance un
espèce de [ __ ] mois